>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, I'm Clara Hughes-Johnson.
I'm very excited to be here with many of you
in mine, old and dear friend and former Googler,
Sara Wampler, but we will not be calling her
that.
[laughter]
This is Sara Ramsey today for purposes in
video posterity, we are being recorded.
Just want everyone to know.
So, Sara, I think we all knew, know, grew
up in Iowa and still returns often to Iowa
to play board games with her family.
[laughter]
'Cause that's what you do, I guess, besides
the corn in Iowa.
Is that fair?
>>Sara Ramsey: That's fair.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: All right.
And went to Stanford and stayed out here and
took a temporary job with Google.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
>>Clara.
And then stayed with us for a long time.
Tried to take a leave to work on her writing.
We just reeled her back in.
She's now out.
Award-winning author of--.
Is romance novel the category, or this like
a sub-category?
>>Sara Ramsey: Romance novel is pretty appropriate.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: You think it's?
OK.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
Historical romance.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Historical romance.
[laughter]
>>Sara Ramsey: It's still a romance.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Is Georgette Heyer
part of the category, or is she not?
>>Sara Ramsey: She is the mother of the category.
So, I'm impressed that you knew who she was.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I read a lot of her
novels when I was back visiting my family
and it was boring.
[laughter]
>>Sara Ramsey: That's pretty much how I got
into it.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: OK.
So, this is exciting.
So, are we--?
I noticed that we don't have any plans for
you to read an excerpt.
>>Sara Ramsey: I think that's probably for
the best.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: OK.
OK.
>>Sara Ramsey: OK, there are 50 books over
here.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: But we do have some
copies for folks.
I'm thrilled.
So, your novel, "Heiress Without A Cause--"
>>Sara Ramsey: Yes.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: has won a couple of
pieces of acclaim.
Can you describe the industry in what those
awards are for people who are maybe not aware?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
So, for those of you who aren't aware, the
romance industry has this, it's this entire
sub-culture that, I think, none of us have
ever laid eyes on until I started going into
it and realized just how many people there
are and how many magazines there are and the
awards and everything like that.
So, this novel, when it was still unpublished,
finaled for the Romance Writers of America
Golden Heart Award, which is given to the
best unpublished romances.
And it gets about 12 hundred entries.
They give it at this conference that draws
two thousand people.
There's about ten thousand people in this
organization.
So, that was exciting.
And then, when it came out, it got four stars
from Romantic Times, which is the industry
magazine.
So, I have the magazine at home and it has
the little blurb in all the covers.
And it's pretty scandalous.
So, it was exciting.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: OK.
So, you sent this entry in.
It won out of 12 hundred entries, which is
amazing.
Then, you self-published.
>>Sara Ramsey: Right.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, talk about that
decision and how it works in industry.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
So, I had, I think it was a lot of you who
knew me, knew I wrote two books and was in
that process when I finally left Google.
The first book won that award and the second
book finaled for that award.
And I got an agent and we were sort of moving
along that path of, "Oh, I'm going to get
a traditional deal and this is going to be
great."
But neither of those books ended up selling.
And the market has been so tough with, I wanna
say economy.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Selling it to a publisher.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
Ever since the economy collapsed, all of big
publishers are part of these bigger media
conglomerates.
So, they're part of like, News Corp or Viacom
or something like that.
And they just can't take the risk on a smaller
author because they're looking at their bottom
line so stringently.
So, my agent, with the first book we were
like, "Oh, just shove it under the bed.
I'll write another one."
'Cause there weren't options at that time.
This was in 2008, 2009.
But now, if Amazon and Barnes and Noble and
I'll give a shout out to eBooks, although
it doesn't quite deserve the same level of
claim, unfortunately.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: All five of them that
sold.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yes.
[laughter]
Yes.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: To people in this
room.
>>Sara Ramsey: Probably.
[laughter]
All of those options have come up for authors
and it's a really exciting time because two
years ago, I couldn't go down this road.
But when I was looking at the numbers, I think,
Clara knows I like brightly colored spreadsheets
that have a lot of numbers all over the place
and aren't necessarily organized according
to business school plans, but they do work.
And they told me that it would be fairly straight-forward
for me to sell enough copies to make as much
as I would've on an advance from a traditional
publisher.
In these days, a publisher may give four thousand
dollars for the first book.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Yeah.
You don't get a lot for your first book, right?
>>Sara Ramsey: Right.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, you're feeling
like you're on with the sales of this self-published,
you're on track?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah, once you all buy a copy
today.
[laughter]
Yeah, it feels pretty good.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Yeah?
>>Sara Ramsey: I mean, I think that it was
the right decision for me.
And I think, too, coming from someplace like
Google, where we're so used to things moving
fast.
If I took six months to get back to Clara
on an email, which I never did, I hope--
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: No.
>>Sara Ramsey: No.
I would've been fired, right?
Whereas in publishing, it's traditional.
My agent sent the manuscript out to these
publishers last April, and by October we still
hadn't heard back from three of them.
And when she would call, she'd say, "Oh, we're
still considering it."
But finally, I was like, "We're gonna pull
this and I'm gonna do it myself."
Because the speed with which the industry's
changing, I couldn't keep sitting there for
a year waiting for them to make a decision.
So.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: All right.
So, what everyone is dying to know is how
does your Google experience prepare you?
[laughter]
So, you talked about lunch, getting a speedy
lunch.
Anyone else, is anyone here in the book?
[laughter]
>>Sara Ramsey: I like how you snuck that in
at the bottom of that question.
I was prepared to go career route.
I'll answer the "is anyone here in the book?"
first.
No.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I mean, come on.
The character--
>>Female #1: Alan Moss.
>>Sara Ramsey: Alan Moss is not in the book.
I can guarantee that.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Loosely based on--.
>>Sara Ramsey: I will say, I'll have little
interactions with people and I don't even
necessarily remember who the person was, but
they'll end up in the book in a different
context.
If I see someone walk funny or do something
a little bizarre, all of those things end
up in the creative process, but it's not like
you can pick out and say, "That character
is Alan Moss" for example.
[laughter]
He's not in the book, I promise.
But, and there was one funny moment where
I realized that I put somebody's last name
in as a placeholder for a servant and then
forgot to take it out.
'Cause I will just try to think of a name
and then, I forgot to take it out.
So, if that person reads this book--.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Like, a last name
is a unusual last name?
[giggles]
>>Sara Ramsey: It's actually not someone in
this room.
It was somebody from one of my dorms at Stanford.
So, that should encourage that corner of this
room to read the book.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: He's a servant.
All right.
Interesting.
So, back to the Google experience.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Novelist.
I think that, as Clara said, I started here
as a temp and I intended to stay for about
six months and was going to go off and get
a PhD in English, which I quickly realized
was not gonna pay any bills at all.
And I really liked Google.
And I think that the longer I stayed, there
were always those days where I felt like I
should be writing a book or pursuing this
passion.
But I will say I don't think I could've been
nearly as successful self-publishing if I
hadn't had the business and marketing experience
that I got here.
Being able to do something like put together
a spreadsheet and say, "This is how much I
would've made this way versus that way," or
working for Clara with the communications
job.
I wrote the back cover copy for my book, which
was a very different skill than writing a
novel.
Writing fiction is very different than saying,
"These are the five words that are gonna appeal
to somebody and this is how I get my message
across."
So, I think from that perspective, even though
the job wasn't related to what I wanted to
do with my writing, all of those little career
things have really helped.
And I think it's easy to lose sight of that
when you're thinking, when you're sitting
in a job thinking, "This isn't what I wanna
do."
It's easy to forget that you're still learning
things that could help you later with that
path.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: And then, I recall
some conversations that it is very lonely
to be home without your Diet Coke soda machine.
>>Sara Ramsey: It's very, very difficult.
[laughter]
The Diet Coke, not the loneliness.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: How did you figure
out, how did you end up sticking with it?
'Cause there were some moments where maybe--
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: you weren't too excited
to stick with it.
>>Sara Ramsey: I'll be open.
There was a moment last spring where I emailed
Clara and I was like, "Can I have my job back?"
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I wasn't gonna say
it, but--.
>>Sara Ramsey: But it was set up for me to
admit that.
[laughter]
Yeah.
I would say that it was hard and I think the
first six months is the hardest.
And that's why--.
When I took my first leave of absence, it
was six months and I came back because it's
not enough time to really break yourself out
of all the habits that you have in a job that
I was really, not just comfortable in, but
really happy with, right?
Like, I didn't leave Google because I was
unhappy.
And so, my first leave, I will admit going
back to Iowa was maybe not the wisest choice
either because board games are great, but
you can only play so many of them before you
start thinking "maybe I need something more."
But my, I think, taking more than six months
to actually get on my feet and moving to the
city helped.
So, I moved to San Francisco.
I was living in this log cabin out in the
woods of Palo Alto, if you can believe they
exist.
I found the one log cabin in Palo Alto.
I think getting more active with my social
life and accepting I have to get out of the
house and take more time.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Yep.
>>Sara Ramsey: I think you know this, too.
Most of the people that I've worked with here
are so driven and goal-oriented that if you're
doing your own thing, it's easy to just spend
all your time doing that, starting to feel
guilty if I'm not making progress on this,
I'm a bad person and I'm wasting my time and
the world's going to explode, which, as it
turns out, is not true.
But that's still a work in progress for me
to figure out how do I have a balanced social
life and still get things done and feel good
about everything that I'm doing.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, how does that
work?
Do you have certain hours that you're writing?
>>Sara Ramsey: You probably know that I'm
not the most organized.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I was like, how do
you procrastinate when--?
>>Sara Ramsey: How do I procrastinate?
I procrastinate pretty well.
I would say if you wanna follow me on Twitter,
I tweet often about the Sarapocalypse, which
involves a lot of glitter.
And my brand name is a little weird.
I'm still figuring out my brand.
I would say, I don't really have set times.
But I try to set number of words per week
that I wanna hit, which I find works better
for me.
I read all these things, like all these famous
authors get up at five and they write until
eight and then they have coffee and then they
read a book and then they write from three
to five.
I could never, I couldn't get up at five for
one thing.
Getting down here was hard enough.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: For a noon--?
[laughter]
>>Sara Ramsey: We had a time change yesterday.
It's only eleven.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: This is really eleven,
yes.
>>Sara Ramsey: And I had to blow dry my hair.
[laughter]
Yeah.
I'm just not that kind of writer.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I can understand that
this morning due to the time change.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I can relate to that.
So, you mentioned you just finished your second,
so this is Book One of the "Muses of Mayfair."
>>Sara Ramsey: Yes.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: And you just finished
Book Two draft.
>>Sara Ramsey: Last night.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Last night.
>>Sara Ramsey: The whole thing.
[applause]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, how long did it
take to write that?
That's what we're trying to get at here.
>>Sara Ramsey: I'm looking at my roommate,
who has seen me not leave my room for days.
That's my roommate.
The interesting thing was that the second
book was actually the first book that I wrote
in 2009.
And so, I wrote that book and it didn't sell
and I put it away.
Gretchen read it.
It didn't sell.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: And Alan Moss was
in it, right?
>>Sara Ramsey: No.
[laughter]
Again, Alan Moss was not in any books.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Just because he didn't
show up, we can do this.
>>Sara Ramsey: I'm saving it until I get really
famous and then I'll write a book just about
him, but I wanna have the audience built-in
so I can take advantage.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: That's fair.
That's a good plan.
So, you rewrote the book.
>>Sara Ramsey: I rewrote.
So, what I initially did was--.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: "Scotsmen Prefer Blondes,"
is the working title.
>>Sara Ramsey: "Scotsmen Prefer Blondes."
Yes.
It's not just the working title.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: It will be the title.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
I don't really [inaudible] title.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I guess if you self-publish,
you can just make the.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: titles.
>>Sara Ramsey: Which is nice.
Yeah.
So, I rewrote the book.
And it was a very painful process because
when I originally intended to self-publish,
I said, "Oh, this is great.
I have two books that are done.
I can get them out back-to-back."
I started advertising when they were coming
out back-to-back.
And then I read it and I was like, "Oh, crap."
Because my writing style has changed a lot.
I've learned a lot as a writer.
I've gotten a lot, I think I've gotten better.
We'll see.
There were things that I legitimately saw
that I could've done better in the first book.
And because I put it away and wrote the second
book to be the prequel, there were continuity
issues.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Mmm.
>>Sara Ramsey: So, I initially though it'll
take me three weeks to fix this.
My roommate’s still laughing because that
was in October.
And I think, looking through it, I probably
kept maybe five to eight percent of the first
version.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Wow.
Just--.
>>Sara Ramsey: I rewrote the entire thing.
Don't do that.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Since October.
So you basically--.
>>Sara Ramsey: If there are any writers in
the room, just throw it away and do something
else 'cause it was really, really painful.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: But that's less than
six months.
I mean, that's, you rewrote basically a whole
book.
>>Sara Ramsey: It's true.
But it was--.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: On the bright side.
[laughter]
>>Sara Ramsey: It's hard to see the bright
side 'cause I haven't slept, but no.
It is good.
I think it was a good process to go through.
I think I'm just worried that this is my process
because I go through these--.
I've written two books, but word-wise, I've
really written four.
And so, I need to figure out is this my process
and I'm just the kind of person who writes
a book and then looks at it and rewrites it?
Or, can I figure out how to do it without
that pain.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I think my battery--.
Oh, no.
I'm OK.
If you look at, I don't know, Jonathan Franzen
or Jeffrey Eugenides, it takes them like,
nine or ten years between books.
So, if you can write two books in a matter
of months, that may be a fair process.
>>Sara Ramsey: I feel like this maybe needs
to be a therapy session and you guys can just
like listen for a while we--.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I'm just like, I don't
think that's a bad thing.
>>Sara Ramsey: I haven't had a one-on-one
with you in a long time.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, back to the--.
So, let's talk about, well first of all, you
talked about your writing style has changed.
Why?
What happened?
Was it getting away from writing emails at
Google?
>>Sara Ramsey: Clara's blog actually really
helped me to find my writing style.
No.
Actually, I think some of that's true.
Like, I think, and I know I shouldn't just
keep pointing at people in the audience for
the sake of YouTube, but Heather, who managed
me several years ago, would get all over me
because my emails were like, this long.
And they always made sense and they were well-written,
but they were novels.
They weren't bullet point things.
And I think my writing style as I've seen
it has changed from--.
That first book I wrote in fits and starts
from 2005 to 2008.
Now, I think my writing is a lot crisper and
the sentences tend to be shorter.
I'm a little more focused on pacing than I
was.
Like, they're not these long, flowery, I'm
in love with the language.
Now, it's more--hopefully--I'm trying to get
more of the character across and I'm not just
using pretty words that are big and formal.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Are these more character-driven
or plot-driven when you think about--?
>>Sara Ramsey: I'd say they're more character-driven.
And that was the big problem with the first
book was that I was so character-driven that
the feedback from the publishers who didn't
decide to buy it was that there wasn't enough
going on.
Like, they were really fun characters and
they loved watching them banter with each
other, 'cause I do like to banter, but nothing
really happened.
Like, they got married.
Great.
And that happens in a romance, but there needs
to be a little more "if they don't have any
conflict, why didn't they just get married
Day One?"
And maybe banter at the wedding and the book's
over.
[laughter]
So, I needed a little more plot.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, crisper writing,
a little more plot, a little more action.
Let's talk about this particular genre.
Is this, how did you decide this is it for
you?
Or is this not?
>>Sara Ramsey: I kind of fell into it.
I don't know if it's, and I think everyone
who's worked with me knows I tend to get bored
with stuff at some point.
So, I don't think that I'll write romance
for the rest of my life.
I'll probably keep coming back to it, though.
And I think the nice thing about romance is
that it's such a huge genre that I can choose
to do other things within it.
I'm working on these historical romances,
but I've got this young adult project on the
side that's not historical at all, that does
have romantic elements.
And I think that it's a great place to work--.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Are you gonna write
that under the same name, or new name?
>>Sara Ramsey: I haven't decided yet.
I mean, the sad thing is I've sort of been--.
Sara Ramsey sounds much more romantic, which
is why I went with it.
Sara Wampler, less romantic, all the way at
the end of the alphabet.
Back when bookstores mattered, I was thinking
I didn't want to be the person on the last
shelf.
I wanted to be closer to like, Nora Roberts
or Julia Quinn, who are big romance authors.
Now, it doesn't matter as much because people
aren't walking into book stores and finding
those books.
But we'll see.
Yeah.
So, I don't know what name I'll write under.
And I don't know that I'll write romance forever,
but I think it's a good--.
It's a great place to build an audience.
Romance readers read a lot of books.
So, the average romance reader probably reads,
I don't know, four to ten a month, which is
huge.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: What's up with that?
[laughter]
>>Sara Ramsey: They like their romance.
And they tend to, but they also tend to read
outside the genre, too.
They don't necessarily just read romance.
They'll also read mystery or fantasy or sci-fi.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Do they write to you?
Do you have fans?
I mean, what's up?
Are they--?
>>Sara Ramsey: I've gotten a couple of fan
letters, which was really crazy.
Yeah.
It's very odd.
If you write dear Sara at SaraRamsey.
com, I will respond to you.
Yeah.
It's odd.
And people, I see things starting to pop up
on blogs where they read the book and they're
giving a review.
Goodreads is a really popular reader site
where people are starting to review the book.
So, it's been, it was pretty exciting the
day that I finally got an email that wasn't
like my mom or somebody sitting in this room
saying that they read the book and they really
liked it.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, what, do they
give you any feedback?
Or is it just--?
>>Sara Ramsey: I didn't--
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Good one.
[laughs]
>>Sara Ramsey: The people who emailed so far,
I know people who have gotten emails that
just rip them apart for being too steamy or
too something or getting their facts wrong
or whatever.
And there was one Barnes and Noble review.
You're not supposed to read the reviews as
an author.
You're supposed to pretend that you're impervious
and that none of it affects you, but I read
every single one.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Yeah, right.
>>Sara Ramsey: And I have a Google alert set
up.
[laughter]
And I don't wait for the Google alert.
I search on Google every day and just look
through all the pages.
[laughter]
'Cause Google alert's like four to ten hours
behind, probably, which is not fast enough.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, we know how you're
spending your morning.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
Oh yes.
The procrastination question.
That's what I do.
Yeah, but there was a--.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: You had one review
that said--.
>>Sara Ramsey: There was one review on Barnes
and Noble that they did not like that the
Duke was treated with disrespect.
[laughter]
Which I found really interesting.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Were they British?
I mean, what's that about?
>>Sara Ramsey: I don't know.
I don't think so.
They said they'd read another book.
They really liked it.
But they didn't like the Duke being disrespected.
So, if any of you care about Dukes, don't
buy the book.
I'm not your target author.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, what about this
quote that's now made it into your bio?
"True story, I had to turn the little overhead
air fan on while reading on the airplane.
I was so flushed from reading the love scenes."
[teasing jeers from the audience]
>>Sara Ramsey: That was another Barnes and
Noble review.
It was like, the first one I got that wasn't
somebody I knew.
And I was like, "Oh, awkward."
'Cause my mom called and was like, "Did you
see the review on Barnes and Noble?"
I was like, "Yes.
I did.
She did get flushed from reading the love
scenes.
Had to turn on the little overhead fan."
I don't know.
People, I can't control reviews.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Are they that steamy?
I mean, I'm gonna take my copy.
Gretchen's like, "Yes."
[laughter]
>>Sara Ramsey: They're steamy, but I would
say they don't dominate the book.
Like, that's how I would put it.
There's, and this is what romance at it's--.
I'm not gonna say I'm romance at its best.
But romance, when it's at its best, is, there
is a full story arc that goes through it and
the characters are the focus.
But there are a few scenes where the sex is
part of their relationship.
And that, their character development and
their emotional arc shows through that, too.
So, where someone like Georgette Heyer, first
of all, they usually didn't admit that they
loved each other until like, the last two
pages.
And then when they did, they might kiss once
and then it's over.
Which is good.
And there's something to be said for that.
But I think romance, always modern romances,
tend to show a couple's entire relationship
and doesn't just close the door when it's
time for them to go off and make babies.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So,--.
>>Sara Ramsey: Or not make babies.
Just, whatever.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, the genre is evolving
from when I read a couple of books, clearly.
And what about this "Fifty Shades of Grey"
thing going on?
Can we talk about this?
>>Sara Ramsey: "Fifty Shades of Grey."
So, how many of you have heard of "Fifty Shades
of Grey?"
[pause]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Yeah.
>>Sara Ramsey: Wow.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: You need to hang with
some moms in the suburbs, which I do.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
It is a suburban mom phenomenon, from what
I've heard.
So "Fifty Shades of Grey" is a trilogy that
originally started as Twilight fanfiction.
So, this woman wrote this story of Bella and
Edward--hate Bella.
Don't tell anybody.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I think you just told
some people.
>>Sara Ramsey: She's like--.
I think I did.
She's useless.
Anyway.
I'm not, so I may not be the target audience.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: She seemed like a
vehicle for other people.
>>Sara Ramsey: She was.
She had no real desires of her own.
Anyway, I'm not going off on that.
So, she wrote this fanfiction, but it had
a BDSM element, which those of you who worked
in AdWords Approval Bin know what that is.
[laughter]
So, bondage, domination, sadism, masochism.
Or, domination, submission.
The D and S mean two different things.
So, they have this--.
"Fifty Shades of Grey" has Bella, who is now
named something else, I don't know, obviously
as a fairly like, vapid and useless girl,
but she ends up attracted to this guy who's
an extreme sexual dominant rather than being
a vampire.
So, they're not vampires anymore.
He's now like dominant.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I don't get how it's
"Twilight."
First of all, I haven't even read it, but
as it was described to me by people who have,
it didn't, the "Twilight" fanfiction thing
got lost in translation.
It's just this particular author got inspired
by that.
This is a British author.
And then, wrote this book that's erotic suburban--.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
So, it's basically erotica.
It's not really a romance.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Drama.
I don't know.
>>Sara Ramsey: I think "Twilight" was really
a romance.
Like, "Twilight" was definitely a young adult
and it had romantic elements, but it's not
like, if you're thinking "Twilight" is a romance
novel, then you should read a romance novel.
Or read "Twilight."
I wouldn't recommend that.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: But what I was getting
at is it seems like that is being treated
in a separate category.
I don't know if it's because it's such a phenom,
but it's also being treated differently because
it has so many more digital downloads than
people buying any physical copies, which would
make sense if you understand the content of
the book.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
It's gigantic.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, what does it make
you--?
I'm getting at this from a business perspective.
I think the thing is moving because of this
particular book.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
Well, I think, and I think that's something
that I was considering when I was writing
my books is that the online space especially,
romance readers went online really fast.
Because if you're reading ten books a month,
having a Kindle makes sense, right?
Like, they're cheaper.
You don't have hundreds of them stacked in
your house.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: You're not on the
airplane with the--.
>>Sara Ramsey: You're not on the airplane
with the cover.
And so, erotica has actually grown tremendously
as a sub-genre of that because of the cover
issue.
If you can sit there and read "Fifty Shades
of Grey" at your coffee shop, and people think
you're reading like Dickens, great, right?
You're in Menlo Park.
You're sitting at Cafe Borrone.
You're secretly reading erotica, which is
good.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Getting out the personal
fan.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
[laughter]
I should get personalized misters that you
can--.
That would be a good giveaway.
Yeah.
So, I think, but I think romance as a whole
is moving steamier, too, because that's where
publishers see the market being.
Publishers are making the most money off erotica.
And so, they keep, one of the rejections we
got for the first book was it wasn't sexy
enough.
Even though, this woman had to turn on her
overhead fan to read a couple of the scenes,
right?
[laughter]
That's the direction they're moving.
But I think the good thing, too, about eBooks
is that there's a market for erotica, but
a book that may have a little bit less of
an erotic focus can still find the audience.
There's definitely people out there, myself
included, who are looking for more of the--
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Like story characters.
>>Sara Ramsey: not sweet historic, but more
of a historical influence rather than just
sexy times.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Well, let's talk about
the historical.
How do you know what you're talking about
there in the "Muses of Mayfair?"
Are you researching the period?
Are you just watching a lot of PBS?
>>Sara Ramsey: So, I read a ton of these.
I read a ton of these before I got started.
So, I have read for, romance novels.
My first one was when I was 12.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Wait.
Just hold on a second.
So, you're getting your historical knowledge
from other romance novels?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
So, that was the point I was going to get
to was that there's now this whole phenomenon
called "Romancelandia," which, if you read
any of these romance blogs, which I'm sure
none of you do, it's this problem where people
have read so many of these--and Georgette
Heyer was the founder of this genre--they've
read so much of her that--not Clara.
Georgette Heyer.
They think that that's the fact.
And so, you read these books where everyone
goes and they waltz all throughout the book.
They do these waltzes.
The waltz wasn't actually in London until
1815.
And even then, it was still really scandalous.
And a lot of people didn't dance it until
the 1820's or 1830's.
But if you don't put it in the book, you run
the risk of--.
Basically you're damned if you do and damned
if you don't because the people who have read
a lot of romance, but haven't studied the
period, think that you made a mistake if you
do something that violates the "Romancelandia"
rules.
But then, if you put them waltzing in like,
1805, you'll get emails from people who are
like, "The waltz wasn't in London and you
treated it with disrespect."
[laughter]
So, I think that's a huge issue.
It's figuring out--.
And a lot of times, I just try to avoid some
of those issues.
I just don't have them.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: But how do you know?
You clearly researched outside of Romancelandia.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
So, I'm part of--.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, Romancelandia
has its own version of our history is what
I'm taking.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: OK.
So, you have done your own research.
>>Sara Ramsey: I have done my own research.
There's an online special interest chapter
of Romance Writers of America, if any of you
are interested, called "The Beau Monde," that
is just Regency historical writers.
They are a wealth of information.
You can send them emails and say, "What kind
of boots would this guy be wearing in April
of this year?"
They know.
I have costume books.
I have a membership to Stanford Library, which
is awesome 'cause they have basically every
historical book you would ever need to research.
When I was writing this first book, where
the heroine is an actress, I was researching
what plays were being put on that year, what
theaters were popular, who the actresses were,
that kind of thing, which was really fun.
And since I minored in History in college,
it's a chance for me to be a huge dork and
read all these books and write it off on my
taxes.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I see.
I see the angle there.
>>Sara Ramsey: Don't tell the IRS either.
This video may not need to go up.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, that's included
in--.
[whispers] Should not have said IRS.
So, that is included in your writing process.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Before or after you
write something.
Do you go back and add historical details?
Or, you research before?
>>Sara Ramsey: I'd say I do some of it before,
figuring out, if there's a main plot point,
like could this woman do this at this time,
I need to know before--as I've discovered--before
I have to rewrite the entire book.
But little things like, what kind of coat
would he wear to this event or who a person
might be at this party, I just make a note
in my manuscript and keep going.
Because if I sat down and researched everything
as it came up, I would just go down rabbit
holes and research for days.
Wikipedia is probably, other than Twitter,
the place where I spend the most of my time
procrastinating.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: All right.
So, we're gonna go to some questions.
So start thinking of your questions.
I'll anticipate one, which is maybe there's
some aspiring novelists or even non-fiction
writers here in the room.
What advice would you give to folks who are
wondering if they have dual or a second career
as a writer coming from where they're sitting
now?
>>Sara Ramsey: Make sure when you leave that
you're ready to leave, so you don't come crawling
back for your job, which is awkward.
And then you say, "Actually, I don't want
it back."
Which is doubly awkward.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Well, luckily, "Are
you sure you want it back?"
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
No.
No, it was pretty obvious.
Clara was very good.
I think this is a very safe place to explore
your writing before you actually go off into
the world and try to write full-time.
There's so much freedom to do your own thing.
There's obviously benefits, which are incredibly
valuable--Diet Coke, all of that.
But I think just, I don't know.
Taking that time to get through that first
manuscript first, I think is really valuable.
I wrote that first manuscript and it won the
award and that was great.
But looking at it now, I realize it really
wasn't ready to be published.
And in my head, because I tend to do things
fairly well and tend to succeed at things
that I want to succeed at, not to talk myself
up too much, but I'm used to that level of
success.
It was really hard when it didn't sell.
And I think going through that process, it
was good that I still had this job to fall
back on, 'cause if I hadn't--not just from
a money standpoint, but if I had been going
through that process of trying to sell the
first book, living alone in my cabin without
being able to come into work every day and
think about something else for a few hours,
I probably would've just gone insane.
Like, it would've been incredibly difficult
emotionally to, if that was my only thing.
So, I think getting to the point where you
feel comfortable that you're truly on that
path before leaving is really important.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Great.
Any other, any questions?
Hi, Kerrie.
>>Female #2: Hi, Sara.
Congratulations.
I wanted to ask about if you did any kind
of workshops or what kind of support network
you had as you were getting towards your publishing?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
So, workshops, there are so many writing resources
out there.
Romance is just a sub-piece of the broader
shadow writing community that exists.
I think the Bay Area is fantastic for it.
There are so many people here who want to
write.
And so, the opportunities are pretty big.
The first things I did were--.
Stanford has great continuing studies classes
in writing.
None of them were romance, but it was still
really helpful to talk to other writers.
I took an historical fiction class, which
was really great.
I know there are other colleges in the area
that do that.
I just was close to Stanford.
And then, any genre that you're writing, with
the exception of literary fiction, 'cause
I think they don't like to band together 'cause
they're too snobby--I didn't say that--mystery,
romance, sci-fi, all of those groups have
their own professional organizations and joining
that was huge.
So, I joined Romance Writers of America.
They have a conference every year.
They put on events.
I'm now part of a San Francisco chapter.
I go to that once a month.
They bring in speakers.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Are the people kind
of people you'd be friends with?
I mean, just--.
>>Sara Ramsey: They are.
[laughter]
This is being taped, so they are actually.
[Clara laughs]
It is a really strange and different world
that I was used to at Google.
The first one I went to was in 2008.
And I think I was probably in the 99th percentile
in terms of youth.
I'm still really young compared to a lot of
romance novelists.
I think a lot, especially in romance, it tends
to be more women who have raised their kids
at least up to toddler age and they're now
starting to do something else.
So, the average age is probably like 48 to
50.
I can't tell.
But yeah.
I mean, with any group, a lot of writers are
pretty introverted, so some of the conversations
can be awkward.
But there are a lot of people who are--.
I think romance novelists get stereotyped
as the woman who sits alone with her cat,
which is why I don't have a cat.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Good call.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
But if you go to these conferences, a lot
of the people are actually lawyers or doctors
or came from someplace like Google.
Basically any broad spectrum of society you
took, you can find a romance novelist in any
one of those.
Which is the same readers.
I know there are secret romance novel readers
in this room who may not talk about it, but
they're out there.
If you would connect and start reading more,
that would be wonderful.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, did you go to
any writer space?
I don't know.
My brother has like, he goes to this place
in New York and they all sit there and write.
>>Sara Ramsey: No.
I don't go to writer's space, but I found
it's really helpful for me if I'm in the last,
if I have been next to last draft of the book
to go away for a few days and just read it
and then figure out how to edit it.
So, about a month ago, I went to Santa Cruz
for four days.
I just got a rental on the beach and read
the book and made my notes and figured it
out and had my little panic attack and then
was good.
Which Santa Cruz isn't that far away.
If someone wanted to have dinner with me,
I could've easily driven here, but it was
just far enough to say, "No, I'm in my writing
space.
I need these few days."
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Other questions?
All right.
Go ahead.
>>Female #3: Comment and a question.
I'm currently tracking my Scottish history,
so if you need any stories I'm happy to provide.
I don't know how scandalous they might be.
So, back to the self-publishing piece.
I'm curious if, when I think about the music
industry and how hard that is for some people
to break into it.
And they've had phenomenons like Justin Beiber
making it through YouTube.
Is there the equivalent for a writer?
I know you have a blog.
I follow you on Twitter.
How do you get no--.
Yes.
Fantastic.
I always know what you're up to.
How does a writer get recognized in the--?
>>Sara Ramsey: It is really tough.
And I think because there isn't that sort
of instant gratification of video on YouTube,
although I'm thinking about ways to use YouTube.
My roommate works at YouTube, so I get talk
in my ear about it.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Yeah.
That'll be interesting.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
But I think there are reader communities out
there.
I mentioned Goodreads.
There's Shellfari, which is affiliated with
Amazon.
There's different places where readers congregate.
Goodreads, I have a love/hate relationship
with because they, some of the communities
can be pretty caustic and tend to review--.
Their reviews tend to skew more negative than
necessarily you would see on like, Barnes
and Noble dot com.
So, each place has their own weird community
and just getting used to that is important.
But I think, I don't know.
The most helpful thing for me right now has
been connecting with other authors who are
more established than me, who then do things
like re-tweet my tweets, or, which I know
sounds ridiculous, but re-tweet my tweets
or share my book on Facebook because they
already have more of an audience than I do.
And so, building that network, I think, through
other authors.
I don't know.
Or maybe we just tell ourselves that 'cause
everyone I interact with on Twitter is either
someone I know or another author.
I don't know that I have more than a dozen
peer readers on Twitter.
But it's our version.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: How many followers
do you have?
>>Sara Ramsey: 750 ish.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: It's gotta be more
than 12 readers.
>>Sara Ramsey: I don't know.
And there's some spambots, too.
But--.
[laughter]
I don't block them 'cause it's really gratifying
to see the numbers like 750.
But Twitter's like our version of like, a
water cooler.
Like, if you sit in your house and you're
all alone, it's our version of being able
to like, get up together and gossip.
So, I don't know, Amy.
There's not a really great way to become a
phenomenon.
I don't know how "Fifty Shades" took off.
I'm baffled.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: We should find out.
All right.
We had another question?
Still have--?
>>Male #1: Yes.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Really.
Is this about Twitter?
>>Male #1: Oh, I have a question.
So, how important is that, so when you are
writing the characters that you told us about
and everything, are they real or realistic,
or are they more like fiction that you made
it up?
How important it is to you that you match
real thought patterns like, across humanity?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
That's a good question.
I think I will fully admit that I'm sure it's
hard for me to have a realistic guy's thought
pattern.
And I try.
But I'm not a guy.
I don't think like a guy.
I think I think more like a guy than I should
sometimes.
But with romance, at least the kind that I
write, it tends to alternate points of view
between--.
Probably two-thirds of it is in the heroine’s
point of view--her thought pattern, her perception
of what's going on.
About a third of it's in the guy's point of
view.
I'll fully admit I probably don't get the
guy right all the time.
I do try to, now it's gonna sound like I'm
stereotyping, but I tend to be a little more
directive in the way he talks.
Women tend to speak more with a question at
the end of the voice and making excuses for
their behavior, apologizing excessively.
And guys don't do that as much.
So, I've thought a little about what I've
seen in the work place, what I've learned
from the trainings we've gone through where
we all do our different colors or our like,
E-N-T-J or P or whatever you are.
And I think about that.
I don't know if the exact speech pattern is
right.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: Do you write a back
story?
Like, a human, like this is a real person
kind of story even though it's not all in
the book?
Do you have it in your head or do you write
it or--?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
I have stuff in my head that never makes it
in the book.
Like, things that happened when they were
kids.
Or, what they wanted to do.
Things that happened off-stage that don't
get referenced.
But for me, it makes them feel a little more
three-dimensional.
And those little details, like could pop up
in future books, which is always fun.
'Cause I do wanna have enough of a consistent
pattern for a character that I don't write
myself into a corner and then discover that
last book I said that he was an orphan and
now I really need him to have a mom.
I need to have an idea of who he is.
And then, if that person is solid enough,
I would never think, "He needs to have a mom,"
because within me, he's never had one.
I don't know if that makes sense.
It's, I don't know.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: No, I get it.
I get it.
It's like the story board.
>>Female #4: Hi.
I'm a long time writer and I've always had
a full-time career, job outside of that.
And so, I'm curious, you talked about that
you created a personal metric for yourself
around words and that you obviously were happy
here.
So, you felt like you needed to leave Google
to be in that space and writing.
So, I'm just wondering if you could say a
little bit more about how it helped you, if
it helped you significantly leaving your full-time
career to go to your other full-time career
to write, in terms of, 'Cause I know you can't
just sit eight, nine, ten times a day and
write.
It doesn't, hours a day.
It doesn't work like that.
So, I'm curious about how did it help you?
Did it help you to really just be in that
space and be away in terms of your productivity
and meeting your goals?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
It's an interesting question because a lot
of the writers I've talked to, when they leave
their full-time jobs, they still write just
as much as they did when they had a full-time
job, which is awkward because you're, "Oh,
I'm still writing five pages a day, but I
don't get paid anymore."
I wouldn't, I would say my productivity has
gone up some, but the time that I would've
spent on my job, I now spend marketing or
networking or building my business plans--just
working on soliciting cover art and things
like that.
I wouldn't say my number of words per week
or month has increased substantially, but
I also like to, I would never shut the door,
I'm not asking for my job back, but I would
never shut the door on going back in a business
capacity, especially with publishing the way
it is.
At some point, if I get bored with writing,
or I see an opportunity, I could see myself
either starting my own publishing, consulting
or going to one of these big eBook places,
like Google if they actually sell a lot of
eBooks.
Yeah.
So, I'm keeping those doors open.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: So, talk about the
cover art for a second.
How did you get that?
Should we show the?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah, the cover art was really
fun.
So, no it's not me.
My brother told me that they put my family's
very cute about this.
When they got their first paperback copy,
they stopped the UPS man and made him wait
for when they opened the box.
And then they gave him my bookmarks.
So, that was nice.
But yeah.
They've apparently put these bookmarks all
over town and they're getting questions about
whether it's me.
So, that's awkward.
It's not me.
But the cover art processes are now, because
so many people are moving to self-publish,
people like cover artists from the old publishing
houses or I hired a freelance editor, who
used to be an editor at Harlequin, they're
moving to do more of their own freelance stuff
'cause they can make more money and have more
reasonable hours than they could being a cog
in the wheel at a publishing house.
So.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: A photo?
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah, it's a photo.
So, if you go to hotdamndesigns.com, this
woman takes all this stock photography.
And so, she has the costumes.
She does all the, stages these things.
You can get not just historical, but paranormal,
contemporary, all of that.
And then, she designs the cover.
So, I sent her, this is what my characters
are like.
I like covers where you can't see the woman's
head.
I don't know why.
But actually, I do know why.
I don't like seeing the person's face and
having that visual when I want to imagine.
So, yeah.
That was fun.
Thank you for humoring me by raising your
hand.
[laughter]
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: I really am.
Especially 'cause I got a free copy.
>>Sara Ramsey: Yeah.
So, Clara gets a free copy.
Everyone else, it's 11.99.
Sorry.
But I take cash or credit card.
And if are really excited about credit card,
I have the little square app, which I know
is not a Google thing, but it's amazing.
It plugs into the iPad so you can just swipe
it.
It's pretty cool.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: [inaudible] Oh.
I think this is still not on.
But anyway.
Any final remarks or pieces of advice or plugs?
Marketing.
This is like one of those talk shows.
>>Sara Ramsey: Follow your dreams.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: And available, you
know?
>>Sara Ramsey: It's available.
It's available on Barnes and Noble, Amazon.
The next one, which I just finished last night,
as I said you're lucky I'm here, will be out
March 29th, which is the huge advantage of
doing this myself, because if it were a traditional
publisher, I would mail it to them, they'd
respond in three months and say, "Great.
Change this stuff."
It would probably be a year to 18 months before
it came out.
So, next one's out.
"Scotsmen Prefer Blondes."
Amy, I'll ask you later if that's true.
[laughter]
OK.
>>Clara Hughes-Johnson: All right.
Well, thank you so much and congratulations.
[applause]
>>Sara Ramsey: Thanks for coming, everyone.